monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
Président Claude madurée
comme vous et comme bon nombre de nos
compatriotes j'ai été profondément
choquée par le déchaînement de violence
ce samedi à Sainte-Soline contre les
gendarmes contre l'ordre républicain
j'ai été choqué de voir des élus se
rendre en écharpe tricolore à une
manifestation interdite
[Musique]
j'ai été choqué ces dernières semaines
d'entendre des élus multipliés les
propos incendiaires et parfois même
justifier les violences
renvoyer dos à dos casseurs et force de
l'ordre c'est indigne de la part d'élus
de la République
alors aujourd'hui avec vous avec les
Français je veux à mon tour rendre
hommage aux forces de l'ordre à leur
courage et à leur engagement
[Applaudissements]
je veux dire ma solidarité aux gendarmes
et aux policiers qui ont été blessés à
Sainte-Soline ou dans les débordements
qui ont malheureusement parfois entouré
les mobilisations ces derniers jours
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs les
policiers et les gendarmes connaissent
leurs devoirs d'exemplarité et de
respect de la déontologie le ministre de
l'Intérieur Gérald Darmanin là encore
rappelé hier des casseurs et des
militants radicalisés venus chercher
l'affrontement et défier nos
institutions sont à l'origine des scènes
que nous avons vu ces derniers jours
notamment à Sainte Soline c'est leur
comportement qui met en danger chacun
policier gendarmes sapeurs-pompiers
secours et même les manifestants alors
de notre côté nous faisons tout pour
éviter que des débordements surviennent
et comme vous tous ici j'ai une pensée
pour les deux manifestants toujours
hospitalisés dans un état très grave
depuis samedi
depuis des semaines le ministre de
l'Intérieur les préfets les forces de
l'ordre au contact des organisations
syndicales travaillent ensemble et ont
permis la tenue de la grande majorité
des mobilisations sans heure nous
continuerons à nous adapter et à réagir
pour que la violence ne supplante jamais
l'expression des revendications c'est le
sens du dispositif qui encadrait la
journée d'hier il a permis d'éviter de
nombreux débordements affrontements
dégradation c'est le sens de la
procédure de dissolution annoncée hier
par le ministre de l'intérieur du groupe
uscules soulèvement de la terre mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs la violence
n'a pas sa place dans les cortèges et
nous sommes déterminés à continuer à
protéger tous ceux qui veulent
t'exprimer pacifiquement leurs idées à
protéger les Françaises et les Français
je vous remercie merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]